bien la communication
come back retour de la messieurs bonsoir
c'est un enfant du siècle qui vient de
mourir assassiné ce matin à new york
john lennon avait 40 entre juste pour ce
tournage pour les plus jeunes aussi
c'était à sa manière un témoin de son
époque bruyante et nostalgie qui nous
laissera tous le souvenir d'au moins un
disque un parmi les 250 millions vendus
depuis quinze ans dans le monde entier
ce sont ces quelques uns de ces millions
de francs que vous avez vu ici nos murs
est l'une de ses dernières chansons
devant son domicile
c'est là en effet que s'est déroulé le
drame la nuit dernière et projets
toutes les télévisions et les chaînes de
radios américaines ont interrompu leurs
programmes pour annoncer la mort de john
lennon la nouvelle s'est répandue comme
une traînée de poudre dans les rues de
new york
les plusieurs centaines de ses
admirateurs ont veillé toute la nuit
devant son domicile du qe3 bordure de
central park
les larmes aux yeux écoutant à la radio
ou sur des cassettes des dernières
chansons de john lennon ils ont évoqué
dans la nuit new yorkaise le temps où
avec les beatles il débarquait pour la
première fois aux états unis au sommet
de sa gloire
les admirateurs de lennon se demande
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi ce jeune
américain de 25 ans david chapman a tiré
à bout portant sur john lennon alors
qu'il rentrait chez lui avec sa femme
après une séance d'enregistrement un
maniaque un admirateur déçus qu'ils
cherchaient désespérément des
autographes
pas de mobile apparent dit la police de
new york qui vient pourtant d'ouvrir une
enquête dans l'entourage du chanteur
l'assassinât de lennon a en tout cas
autant d'impact ici aux etats-unis que
la mort d'elvis presley
oui pour beaucoup john lennon c'était la
tête pensante de ce groupe qui ne
s'était plus réunie sur une scène depuis
des années ce soir aucun de ses trois
amis dispersés pour la vie n'a jamais
encore vous lui parlez pas plus paul
maccartney que george harrison ou ringo
starr gérard holtz nous rappellera en
fin de journal qui furent les beatles et
qui fut donné nos économies ce que nous
laissions entendre hier avec lips acier
est aujourd'hui avéré matra a bien pris
une importante part situation chez
hachette sans doute même la principale
jean luc lagardère le pdg de matra se
refuse toujours à confirmer tout à fait
la formation est encore prématuré dutil
mais le rapprochement ne fait de doute
pour personne
la banque de gestion financière à
d'ailleurs confirmé qu'elle avait pris
une participation de 41% du capital de
hachette
c'est ainsi que matra qui avait déjà de
multiples hic de multiples ramifications
étant maintenant largement son empire
dans la presse et la communication
ce satellite de télécommunications va
peut-être devenir le nouveau symbole de
matra près la voiture de course et les
missiles avec la compétence acquise dans
les technologies de pointe les hommes de
matra jean luc lagardère en tête vis
aujourd'hui autre chose tout à fait dans
la ligne de la civilisation
d'électronique et du microprocesseur la
télématique
c'est à dire la presse de demain cette
presse qui ne sera plus fait de papier
mais de petits écrans de télécopieurs
voici quelques-uns de ses appareils
télématique matra fabrique
mais cela ce n'est qu'un contenant reste
à trouver maintenant le contenu ce que
vous lirez chez vous ce dont vous aurez
envie ou besoin dans l'avenir et que
vous recevrez à travers ces écrans le
contenu c'était europe numéro un les
dernières nouvelles d'alsace 7
aujourd'hui l' empire achète
l'audiovisuel existait déjà chez matra
il existait aussi chez hachette
avec ce rapprochement avec ce
rapprochement l'audiovisuel va se
trouver en force pour permettre
peut-être la création de ce que visait
depuis très longtemps matra avec le
contrôle de l'espace la télévision
jauron à sa télé de télé diffusion
directe pourra vous envoyer les images
que vous recevrez directement chez vous
sans aucun contrôle politique peut-être
à ce moment là une chaîne privée
verra-t-elle le jour c'est un désespoir
de matra et ça pour beaucoup dans la
presse écrite c'est un peu
la mort du papier il ya matra il ya
aussi son patron jean luc lagardère dont
le moins qu'on puisse dire est qu'ils ne
manquent pas de personnalité et
d'ambition réécouter ce qui nous vivait
il y a neuf mois sur le plateau
d'antenne de midi objectif d'une société
industrielle et d'un groupe comme celui
de matra n'est pas de dire on veut faire
du profit du profit à tout prix c'est à
nous c'est un mauvais calcul
mais je dis qu'on en fait qu'on en fait
beaucoup parce que justement le premier
objectif consiste à être en tête dans le
domaine technique je pense que l'on
parlera tout à l'heure à créer dans la
dans l'entreprise en climat un esprit
qui est un esprit de conquête de gagneur
et en étant bien entendu organisé avec
rigueur le profit suis naturellement on
investit on développe et le profit su si
on cherche le profit pour le profit
c'est trop de court terme et je pense
que ce n'est pas la bonne solution
et finalement si ce n'est pas le profit
la finalité suprême d'un groupe
industriel c'est quoi pour vous et bien
c'est de faire des choses positives qui
dans leurs créneaux sont à la tête de la
compétition mondiale
c'est ça essentiellement oui jean luc le
gall air qui est à la tête d'un empire
un empire qui s'est accrue d'une
concentration aujourd'hui ce qui a pas
risque de monopole le copain bien oui
certainement et jeu mais je crois que ce
n'est pas seulement la constitution de
ce que l'on a appelé dès aujourd'hui
elle à la naissance d'un géant de la
communication qui pose cette question
mais aussi toute une évolution de
caractère technologique car cet
événement même s'il faut bien le dire a
surpris elle nous a surpris et quand il
était connu hier et finalement était
sinon prévisible du moins logique dans
la mesure où il s'inscrit dans la
préparation de ce qui se passera dans
les années 85 90 il est certain que
l'entrée en jeu des satellites de
télécommunication direct et que les
moyens nouveaux qui vont mettre la
disposition les les besoins nouveaux
qu'ils vont créer aussi en images et
puis aussi l'apport de capitaux autre
que la simple redevance vos créé une
situation nouvelle dans laquelle le
monopole sera effectivement concernés il
y aura une question politique au sens
large c'est celle de la réplique du
service public à cette situation est
plus une question peut-être de
caractères plus professionnelle qui sera
la réplique des chaînes à toute
concurrence éventuelle et leur
adaptation aux évolutions qui sont en
train
de se produire vous savez d'ailleurs
déjà 41 2 nous avons eu l'occasion
d'étudier de réfléchir ce que l'on
appelle désormais les futurs de la
télévisi la prespective s'inquiète de ce
rapprochement de cette concentration
elle s'inquiète et elle se mobilise une
partie même d'entre elles accusent le
gouvernement d'être le complice voire
même l'aspirateur de l'opération qui
vient de se produire
il est vrai que la presse s'est toujours
inquiètes lorsqu'il ya ces fameuses
concentration lors ce que se constitue
des empires de presse car c'est bien sur
le pluralisme de la presse qui peut être
mise en cause et il ya là aussi un
problème politique un problème politique
qui devrait préoccuper le gouvernement
et les gouvernements suivants qui auront
toujours comme devoir de sauvegarder les
conditions du pluralisme de la presse
mais il ya là aussi je crois comme pour
la télévision un problème professionnel
car la constitution d'un groupe comme on
dit multimédia est une sorte de défi qui
est adressé à chacun des médias de
s'adapter précisément aux
bouleversements technologiques dont la
constitution de ce groupe est le signe
avant-coureur toujours dans les grandes
manoeuvres industrielle la tentative de
dialogue entre japonais et français
tout à l'heure c'est raymond barre qui
recevait les industriels des deux pays
qui participent à ce que l'on appelle
une bilatérale franco japonaise et qui
leur a rappelé que s'il jaf on vendait à
la france beaucoup de produits
manufacturés l'averse mais c'est pas
vrai le polémiste se refuse à un
protectionnisme permanente mais ne veut
pas non plus que la pénétration
japonaise bloque le développement de
secteurs entiers
raymond barre ne souhaite pas non plus
une quelconque division du travail entre
les deux pays en tout cas si quelque
chose peut rapprocher paris et tokyo
c'est bien de pétrole ni là ni notre nom
et du côté des prix de l'or noir à la
veille de la réunion de l'opep à bali
l'atmosphère pour la première fois
depuis longtemps paraît être à la
détente d'une part les pays producteurs
réunis hier à couettes d'autre part les
grands pays consommateurs réunis
aujourd'hui à paris avec l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie des deux
côtés et ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'on
s'efforce de manoeuvrer pour contenir la
hausse
pierre marie diagne 21 pays grands
consommateurs de pétrole 21 pays riches
réunis dans des locaux à leur mesure le
château de la muette à paris c'est l'
agence internationale de l'énergie
bien que la france ne participe pas
directement à ces travaux le résultat
nous intéresse au premier chef puisqu'il
peut influer sur les prix du pétrole
un souci le freinage des spéculations
qui joue sur les marchés libres est le
niveau des stocks et tire le pétrole à
la hausse
coordonner les stockages réduire les
achats spéculatifs continuer à
restreindre la demande
c'est le programme est la volonté qui
ont été affirmés ce soir et qui peuvent
aider les pays consommateurs a remonté
la pente en sens inverse et presqu'au
même moment les pays arabes membres de
l'opep réunis au koweït convenait qu'il
était pour eux plus urgent de remettre
un peu d'ordre
avant de songer à de nouvelles hausses
alors que deux des leurs l'iran et
l'irak sont en guerre reprise partielle
des exportations irakiennes absence
générale de propositions extrémistes à
une semaine du sommet de l'opep à bali
l'atmosphère de cette réunion du coct
veille d'être bonne augure de quoi
ramener enfin au moins provisoirement un
peu d'optimisme sur le front du pétrole
lorsque les saoudiens ont prêché la
modération ils ont été applaudis à
propos des mesures décidées hier par le
chef de l'état alors des pme une
réaction du rpr ce soir qui s'élèvent
contre la politique des cadeaux qui
consiste à dico de la baie à distribuer
des milliards à chaque occasion sans
autorisation parlementaire préalable
roger chinaud de son côté kyi et le son
collègue de l'udf s'est déclaré
stupéfait par les déclarations
de son collègue donc claude labbé voilà
plus de six semaines qu'il était au
courant dit il parti communiste dans
l'humanité d'aujourd'hui une liste de 12
100 intellectuels appelant au soutien de
la candidature de georges marchais et
puis les douaniers en grève vendredi
l'appel des cinq grandes centrales
syndicales il souhaite une amélioration
des effectifs et de meilleures
conditions de travail depuis napoléon
promet du style il n'y a eu aucune
augmentation du personnel premier
rapport d'activité de la commission
informatique et libertés il y a deux ans
et qui pour la circonstance a décidé de
décentraliser ses activités elle s'est
rendue aujourd'hui à lille dans une
région où l'ordinateur a déjà beaucoup
de poids sommes tout près des grandes
maisons de vente par correspondance
bernard pradines eaux étaient sur place
la commission informatique et liberté
qui n'a pas d'équivalent à l'étranger
veut éviter aux français la tyrannie de
l'ordinateur l'informatique ne doit pas
porter atteinte à la vie privée ni aux
libertés individuelles ou publiques
la mission essentielle de la commission
et donc de contrôler tous les fichiers
informatisés qui existe est de donner un
avis sur la création de nouveaux or on
compte actuellement 250 milles fichiers
au moins public ou privé ceux de l'edf
de la police de la sécurité sociale des
pentes les fichiers de la vente par
correspondance les cartes grises des
hôpitaux
il ya même un commerce florissant de ces
fichiers entre sociétés plus
l'ordinateur frontières d'informations
sur vous et votre famille
plus les risques de vous classer en bon
ou mauvais citoyen existe
un certain nombre d'utilisateurs de
l'informatique rassemble des
informations sans savoir à quoi elles
serviront et il est possible qu'un jour
ces informations puissent être
préjudiciable avait privé ou aux
libertés ainsi il y a un projet
concernant les cartes électroniques de
paiement bien quand ce système sera au
point il est évident qu'il sera possible
de suivre à la trace le détenteur de
cette garde on saura que tel jour à
telle heure il en a réalisé tel achat à
tel endroit
or il y à une liberté fondamentale et
avec elle les français plus que d'autres
sont attachés à la liberté d'aller et
venir
la commission a déjà donné plusieurs
avis elle a fait infléchir certains
projets administratif à propos des
douanes du téléphone du casier
judiciaire de la carte d'identité unique
elle a donc un poids politique son
premier rapport aujourd'hui prouve
qu'elle existe et que son travail ne
fait que commencer
la commission informatique et libertés
voudrait maintenant défendre mieux
encore les libertés publiques comme la
liberté d'expression où la liberté du
travail
la maîtrise de l'ordinateur est l'une
des conditions de la solidarité entre
les citoyens à l'étranger toujours la
pologne en tête de pont il ya une heure
un télégramme en provenance de
washington mais d'origine incertaine
nous apprenait que l'urss aurait demandé
le passage de quatre divisions à travers
le territoire polonais et ce ne sont
pour l'instant que de simples rumeurs
le président du comité militaire de
l'otan disait en début d'après midi que
le dispositif soviétique n'avait pas
bougé à la frontière les ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'otan vous le
savez s'étaient réunis hier et il avait
répété qu'il n'interviendrait pas
militairement mais qu'il y aurait des
mesures limitées pour éviter que la
situation ne fasse tache d'huile
certains à washington dans la nouvelle
administration reagan crois beaucoup à
l'imminence de cette nouvelle
intervention soviétique
c'est le cas de gérard holtz l'ancien
numéro deux de la cia l'un des
conseillers du nouveau président mais
qui ce soir sur antenne 2 a souhaité
s'exprimer à titre personnel il répond à
paulhan je crois que la menace qui pèse
sur la [ __ ] est réel et je pense
qu'elle est même imminente général
personnellement vous avez l'impression
donc que les soviétiques interviendront
interviendront en pologne
militairement bien drôle je crois que
cela est fort probable
bien que le coût d'intervenir sera très
élevé le coût de ne pas intervenir
serait pour eux encore plus élevé c'est
à dire s'ils n'interviennent pas cela
démontrera que le communisme n'est pas
irréversible alors qu'eux ils tiennent à
ce que l'on sache qu'une fois le
communisme installé au pouvoir il n'y a
pas moyen pour le peuple de le chasser
l'armée rouge interviendra ou qu'il
faudra pour maintenir un régime
communiste au pouvoir
voilà la leçon qu'il va être donné pour
éviter la finlandisation de l'europe
orientale
mon général mais quelle serait la
réaction des occidentaux des américains
de votre gouvernement
je crois que la réaction des américains
dépendra en grande partie de la
rédaction des européens
notre difficulté en attaque américain
c'est qu'on nous demande de faire
quelque chose il si nous le faisons on
dit que nous sommes belliciste si nous
ne faisons rien on dit que nous sommes
des tigres en papier
il faudrait vraiment qu'une fois
l'europe nous suivent dans cette
question nous accompagnent je ne dis pas
suivent mais nous accompagnent dans
cette question car la menace est
beaucoup plus grave pour l'europe que
pour les états unis d'une occupation
soviétique de la pologne en ce moment
par exemple l'allemagne est en train de
prêter 14 milliards de marks à l'union
soviétique
probablement avec garantie du
gouvernement américain pour la
construction d'un pipeline de gaz
naturel au coeur de l'europe qui mettra
l'europe dans la dépendance économique
de l'union soviétique pendant des années
à venir
ceci à un moment nous avons cherché à
faire adopter par nos alliés enfin des
mesures de rétorsion envers l'union
soviétique pour l'afghanistan et que
voyons nous un de nos principaux alliés
est en train de leur prêter 14 milliards
de marks pour mettre l'europe dans une
situation encore plus dépendante de
l'europe
et puis on dit qu'est ce que vont faire
les américains et j'ai l'exemple vous
donnez nous nous en prenons notre temps
on a appris tout heures que deux zones
interdites ou représentants militaires
occidentaux en allemagne de l'est
allez être réouverte à minuit donc le
signe d'une certaine détente qui nous
frappe un petit peu dans cette avalanche
d'informations que nous recevons
essentiellement en provenance des états
unis
c'est la précision des renseignements
tous ne sont pas confirmées par les
événements mais la plupart sont
extrêmement précis alors comment est ce
possible
essentiellement grâce aux écoutes radio
la pologne les troupes de l'otan
stationnées en allemagne fédérale mais
surtout à berlin sont particulièrement
vigilantes à tous les signaux venus de
l'est européen observations et
renseignements sont donc devenus des
activités clés pour les militaires et
leurs oreilles électroniques sont
braqués au delà de la porte de
brandebourg
au delà du mur de berlin sur la base de
ce travail et des échos recueillis par
les systèmes radio et radars on sait
maintenant qu'un dispositif
d'intervention s'est mis en place de
notre côté on sait avec précision qu aux
frontières de la pologne du côté
est-allemand comme du côté soviétique
les communications et liaison radio
entre les militaires soviétiques ont
pratiquement doublé durant les deux
dernières semaines ce qui indique des
concentrations de blindés et de troupes
soviétiques en état d' alerte à c'est à
dire prête à une action immédiate
ainsi on évalue entre 300000 et 500
mille hommes le potentiel des unités en
alerte
de fait ces renseignements tirés de l'
écoute et de l'analyse du trafic radio
militaire des troupes du pacte de
varsovie recoupe les observations des
satellites américains dont les caméras
scrutent en permanence le territoire
soviétique afin d'identifier le moindre
mouvement de troupes ce qui avait
d'ailleurs déjà permis de prévoir
l'invasion de l'afghanistan
on n'a pas pas une tension entre
varsovie et moscou à propos de
manoeuvres contre révolutionnaire c'est
ce qu'annonce l agence tass vous le
voyez pendant ce temps les nombreux
jeunes étaient toujours en un mais c'est
essentiellement de l'afghanistan qu'il a
parlé avec in iraq anti tchad
de violents combats aujourd'hui
n'djamena il est impossible de vérifier
s'il ya eu ou non participation libyenne
et puis l'italie avec toujours l'épreuve
de force entre les quelques 250 mille
sinistrés de la région de naples et les
autorités qui veulent les pousser à
quitter la région
la région détruite mais la plupart
d'entre eux veulent rester sur la terre
de leur mort ils veulent reconstruire
cet art portage de gérard ine
meli tôt un village de 1250 habitants en
plein coeur de la zone sinistrée détruit
complètement en 1962 par un tremblement
de terre aujourd'hui reconstruit avec
des normes antisismiques
ce village a résisté à 70 secondes de
secousses au vote
ici nous avons ressenti le tremblement
de terre très fortement tout a bougé les
maisons ont tenu il y a dix huit ans
nous avons déplacé notre village de
quelques centaines de mètres et
reconstruit de façon anti sismiques
nous y étions obligés car les autorités
nous avait classé en zone dangereuse
le financement a été pour 60% à notre
charge
mais c'est tous les villages de cette
région qui aurait dû être construit
ainsi à quelques kilomètres de ce
village santangelo dit lombardi
cette ville de lotir pini comptait plus
de 5000 habitants
tout a été détruit la vieille ville
comme les immeubles neufs
il ya eu plus de 1000 morts le dos cassé
par un sac poubelle pleins de vivre
cette femme comme les autres habitants
de cette ville a tout perdu ou presque
personne ici ne veut de l'exode proposé
par les autorités l'hiver sera rude
ils le savent la nourriture arrive et
vêtements chauds aussi alors ils se sont
installés dans des tentes d'autres dans
des roulottes
ils tiendront nous ont ils dit leurs
espérances une roulotte et un repas
chaud
dès les premiers jours passés ils se
sont habitués à cette ville soudain
transformé en chantier un nouvel épisode
les bulldozer sont entrés en manoeuvre
le tri dérisoire des habits récupérables
des casseroles bosselé et bien finie
santangelo est mort santangelo vivre à
nous at on dit mais tout le monde se
demande comment il sera reconstruit
comme les liteaux le village anti
sismiques ou comme les immeubles neufs
de la ville qui se sont écroulés à
naples les autorités n'ont pas voulu
nous répondre sur ce point le temps de
la reconstruction n'est pas encore à
l'ordre du jour
une inquiétude supplémentaire pour cette
région qui sur 50 km de long à basculer
dans le néant
on vient d'apprendre une petite
demi-heure une quinzaine de prêtres
traditionalistes avaient occupé dans le
calme mardi donc aujourd'hui en fin
d'après midi l'église notre dame des
victoires place des hypers donc à paris
dans le 2ème arrondissement c'est prêtre
ne se situe pas dans la mouvance des
traditionalistes de monseigneur le faire
les obsèques de romain gary cet après
midi en l'église saint-louis des
invalides aux côtés de sa compagne et de
son fils diego on pouvait remarquer la
présence de jacques chaban delmas de
bestioles de jean d'ormesson et de très
nombreux compagnons de la libération
la cérémonie religieuse s'est terminée
sur une mélopée russe et un détachement
de l'armée de l'air a rendu les honneurs
à celui qui fut un ancien de
l'escadrille le rennes romain gary est
et à signer ray au cimetière du père
lachaise sport c'est le suédois stenmark
y arriver le meilleur temps à la
première manche du slalom spécial de
madonna di campliglio le second est
encore un suédois
textron et puis voile voici la première
interview de ce garçon dont je vous
parlais hier isp estelle 338 jours
autour du monde sans toucher terre
depuis samedi
yves questel est donc de retour à
cherbourg plus vieux de 18 mois pluvieux
surtout de l'expérience qu'il vient de
vivre un tour du monde à la voile en
solitaire
trente mille milles à bord de ce pic à
un bateau de 9 mètres qu'il a construit
en partie lui même
trente mille milles via le cap de
bonne-espérance l'océan indien et le cap
horn au milieu des calmes les plus plats
et des tempêtes
plus violentes au départ de cherbourg le
5 juillet 1979
if estelle a rempli ses cales de vivre
il pense pouvoir tenir un an sans faire
escale mais boucler la boucle
seul et sans mettre pied à terre yves
questel ignore ce 5 juillet 1979 s'il en
est capable
il espère aller le plus loin possible
pour des raisons qui lui appartiennent
c'était surtout pour vivre vivre un
petit peu autre chose que ce que j'avais
vécu ici et puis essayer de te mettre
des choses au point alors tout seul
évidemment c'est sépare pas très facile
séparent mais ça permet de remettre
beaucoup de choses en place est ce que
c'est un défi un tour du monde tout seul
non c'est pas du tout un défi non c'est
pas du tout un défi de vouloir vivre de
vouloir vivre spontanément une vie qui
peut-être paraît différente des autres
mais qui est avant tout de vivre la
météo et bien vous le voyez il a encore
fait très frères noté à -7 à lyon - 4 à
dijon et nancy mais tout de même plus 6
degrés à pourrait plus suite à nice
demain sur les régions voisines de la
manche le nord du bassin parisien et de
la picardie temps moins froid mais très
nuageux avec risque de verglas sur
l'auris thriller reste de la france
pardon temps froid avec des gelées
matinales puis ciel quand même vous
voyez assez ensoleillé
comme promis maintenant gérard holtz
nous retrace la carrière de john lennon
qui a donc été assassiné ce matin à
l'aube à new york
tout a commencé ici dans une boîte de
nuit de liverpool
la caverne john lennon rencontre paul
mccartney puis george harrison et ringo
starr le batteur sommes en 1962 les
beatles viennent de naître
pendant dix ans ils vont régner sur le
monde de la musique de variété en
angleterre d'abord en europe aux
états-unis depuis partout dans le monde
dix années de règne absolu sur la
musique sur la musique mais aussi sur le
comportement de milliers d'adolescents
et de fans qui vont copier leurs
coiffures leur façon de s'habiller de
parler et journalistes les sociologues
appellent cela la beatlemania entre 1962
et 1968 john lennon et paul mccartney
vont écrire les paroles et les musiques
de plus de 100 chansons
beaucoup d'entre elles sont des énormes
succès comme get back par exemple
yet bac qu'ils avaient chanté sur le
toit de leur studio d'enregistrement
comme cadeau à la foule qui les
écoutaient dans ma
les beatles étaient quatre mais tout le
monde le savait john lennon qui était
leur âme leur cerveau celui qui pensait
un peu plus que les autres celui qui
parle est aussi plus que les autres
l'une de ces petites phrases provoquera
un tollé les beatles sont plus connus
que jésus-christ avec elie
une chose est certaine avec bob dylan
john lennon est celui qui a le plus
influencé les années 60-70 dans le
domaine de la chanson
john lennon s'intéresser à tous les
sujets prenez parti voulait se battre
pour ceux qui pensent être les bonnes
causes contre la guerre du vietnam pour
le bangladesh pour les handicapés pour
la classe ouvrière et pour les femmes
l'une d'entre elles d'ailleurs va
compter plus que les autres dans sa vie
yoko ono d'une japonaise qu'il va
épouser certains critiquent expliqueront
même qu'elle est la responsable de la
dissolution du groupe des beatles
depuis la séparation des beatles john
lennon vivait à new york avec yoko ono
une sorte de retraite consacrée à
enrichir sa culture personnelle
consacrer à son fils et à sa femme aussi
j'aimerais bien venir à paris mais pour
l'instant je ne peux pas quitter paris
me manque beaucoup savez mon premier
arrêt quand j'aurai ma carte de
s'organiser pour acheter quelques
vêtements décents au revoir ben oui
bonsoir
voilà dernier journal patricia jeanneney
à 23h30 demain antenne de midi jacques
chirac dans un autre registre là de
paris et puis nous nous retrouvons à
20h10
mais
m
il ya un moment
bien
ja
là
mais bon
il ya sûrement
en
oh
m
non